Hogwarts Legacy has been out in the
world for about a month now but so many
fans have already completed the game to
100 some even doing full second third
and fourth playthroughs with each of the
four houses or even attempting crazy
challenges like trying to complete the
game using only plants remarkable plants
aren't they I hope they weren't too much
trouble oh see any bite marks or missing
digits but even if you're someone still
making your way through the game or
perhaps a PS4 Xbox One or switch player
still waiting for those versions here
are 7 ideas for Avalanche I think would
be nice quality of life editions for
anyone regardless of where you are in
your journey with Hogwarts Legacy and to
be clear we're focusing on quality of
life improvements they can make to the
current game not necessarily big DLC
type ideas now as much as we all want
DLC and future stories within this world
there are already some things within the
current game that could extend its
replay value so let's start with the
number one item that I would personally
love to see added and that is a new game
plus mode I finally reached level 40
just the other day doing our live stream
over on Twitch and now I'm such a high
level with upgraded armor specific
traits talents all this stuff applied to
my gear there's really not much of a
challenge left when it comes to combat
in the game and that's even with me
playing on hard mode now one argument
may say well that's true you're level 40
you should be one-shotting a lot of
things now but how awesome would it be
if there was something even more for
those of us who wanted that additional
layer of a challenge now I actually
think the Hogwarts legacies difficulty
modes are great they don't just turn the
enemies into bullet sponges when you put
it on hard the enemies are actually
going to be more aggressive which is
nice to see and while the game gives you
the ability to explore the world and
finish out all your side quests
everything you want to do to get 100
even after the credits roll there's no
way to carry all of those talents and
upgrades forward to a brand new game
with an increased difficulty which is
what I would love to see in a new game
plus mode it's amazing to see how many
people have already 100 of this game but
one thing I keep hearing is that fans
are looking for even more reasons to go
back and replay the game even after
having all of the trophies completed
offering a new game plus mode with this
scaling difficulty where you carry
everything over into a second
playthrough I think would be a great way
to do just that make the game even
harder for us because trust me man there
are so many amazing spells in this game
amazing Combos and again when you spec
your talents in just the right way right
now even on the hard difficulty it is
just not that hard because of how
powerful you are in fact even as much as
I love this game one of my criticisms is
the fact that they have all of these
great systems in place a gear the traits
the talents all of that stuff but it's
just not really necessary with the
current difficulty of the game I don't
know man maybe that's another idea for
some kind of crazy run where you do no
talents at all no spell upgrades and see
how far you can make it through because
I honestly think you could do it even on
hard mode without upgrading too much so
additionally Hogwarts Legacy could
further extend its replay value by
simply giving players the option to
repeat certain activities like two
prominent minigames that are featured
did you ever think about the fact that
it's kind of strange you can repeat the
broom trials you can actually go back
and try to get a better high score
however summoner's Court cross wants
they just go away so let's start with
summoner's court which I think is a
straightforward but fun minigame
involving the accio spell where you
compete against other Hogwarts students
and even one Professor to score points
there are five of these matches in total
and while they can be repeated as many
times as you want once you manage to
secure that Victory the match is no
longer accessible I'd love to see
Avalanche make this a permanent minigame
where we can challenge each of the five
opponents again anytime we want I
enjoyed how summoner's court kept things
fresh by putting a new variation on the
game each time they would add new
obstacles to the board I just wish we
had a way to replay each of them go for
high scores try to get it as perfect as
we can who knows maybe it's even
possible to add more difficulties for
each of the opponents but in terms of
like the really low hanging fruit for
things they could tackle I think this
would be a very easy one because of the
fact I mean it's already in the game
everything's there everything's built
might get a little crazy if you try to
increase difficulty and stuff like that
but in terms of just putting the games
in there where you can repeat them again
I don't think should be too big of a
problem and then while we're at it what
about more crossed wands this helpful
introduction to combat just sort of
ended up probably I'll be honest dude I
expected this dueling Club to continue
throughout the school year more
opponents increasing challenges to match
but I definitely never thought the club
would just end and then no longer give
us the option to practice against other
students or even the training dummy so
adding more opponents maybe that
Ventures too far into like DLC territory
but again like summoner's Court I'd love
to see the original dueling matches get
added back just as repeatable events and
I know Avalanche has been been very
concerned about story and lore and
making sure all of that fits together
but I mean this could be as simple as
you approaching Luke and Bradley and
saying hey I'd like to get the group
together again for maybe another cross
one session you have a little loading
screen maybe a cut scene and then it
just goes right into even the exact same
thing we did before even better if they
could add some more opponents though of
course I just think it would be really
nice to have an area where you can
practice and try out all these different
spell combinations because again I am so
loving the spells in this game and
experimenting with different spell
diamond setups so I think it would be
great to have this year but we can just
go and practice and work on combos
anytime we want and speaking of spells
and Duels how about some adjustments to
the spell diamonds I mean without a
doubt one of these strengths of Hogwarts
Legacy is certainly it's combat I mean
just kind of across the board people are
talking about how fun and unique this
combat system is so the combat is great
and also the number of spell options
that you have When approaching these
various combat scenarios of course
there's the field guide which gives you
a few hints on some ways to approach
enemies in a more strategic way and what
I love is with the right traits and
talent Supply just about any kind
combination of spells can be viable even
for late game so long as you have a
balance of force control and damage so
you can tackle those different Shields I
mean I just recently posted my full
ranking of all the spells in the game
and it was really difficult to make I
knew there were going to be a lot of
angry people in the comments and that's
happened but the reason they're angry is
because they have these spells that they
know and love and that they work very
well and then they see I actually rank
them low but in reality I think what's
really going on here is that there are
just so many viable combinations of
spells in this game which really speaks
to the quality of job I think the combat
team did on Hogwarts Legacy so the way I
have things set up currently is I've
been using three of the four spell
diamonds for combat and kind of like
Exploration with the fourth really being
reserved for the requirement and the
variums Beast capturing that sort of
thing but the big issue here is that the
room of requirement and vivarium spells
aren't needed outside this specific area
the Beast bag is really the only one
when you look at spells like the Beast
feed the petting brush all the others I
mean they have to take up a spot in our
slottable spell list and you only have a
maximum of 16 slots even when you fully
upgrade this so here's what I would
propose I think it would be awesome to
see a completely different set of spell
diamonds that take over when you enter
the room of requirement there's a few
different ways they could handle this I
mean they know more about games than I
do but just as a fan out here some ideas
I have is maybe they could give you two
new spell diamonds that only show up
when you're in that room it'd be even
fine if the other ones go away right I
mean you don't really need all those
other spells maybe you need your basic
shot for interacting with some things in
the vivarium but all the other stuff you
don't really need there so let's say you
walk in there and then you just have two
completely new spell diamonds they could
even already set them up for you even
give you the option to customize those
further but just have two in there and
it's only the vivarium in room of
requirement spells then as soon as you
exit the room they can have it set up to
where your normal spell diamonds just
reappear again and the benefit in all of
this is that you would now be able to
slot all 16 spells purely for combat
exploration you don't have to worry
about swapping things out every time you
needed to enter the rumors requirement
and can we talk about just how gorgeous
some of these areas are in the room of
requirement but I mean throughout the
game right it's in incredible the
visuals here as you're flying around the
castle so many great moments that would
be perfect for a photo mode I've been
banging the table for photo mode for a
while long before the game even came out
and look I get it it's not gonna be a
priority there are things way higher on
the list than giving people the option
to run around and take photos right but
there are so many breathtaking areas in
Hogwarts across the Scottish Highlands
hogsmead we absolutely need a photo mode
added now the console makers have made
it easier than ever for players to share
screenshots from games things to
features like the share button and
direct integration with social media
platforms and one of the incredible
modes we've seen become more prominent
in recent years is that of a photo mode
now I've had some questions before
people saying well what's the difference
in just taking the snapshot with your
console right well most of these photo
modes are going to differ from Simply
snapping a screenshot by disabling all
the HUD elements automatically they will
typically show the game with all of its
graphical effects regardless of any
performance or Fidelity mode settings
elsewhere since the game is locked in
one position when you're in that photo
mode frame rate it's not going to be a
concern when this mode is active which
is why the game can display everything
at the highest possible Fidelity some of
the more advanced photo modes even give
you the option to change things like
weather time of day the expression on
your character's face to get that
absolutely perfect shot and it's really
difficult to get Universal praise with
anything online especially when it comes
to video games but I don't think I've
seen many people complain about photo
modes I mean even those who don't spend
a lot of time using it I think they love
going online and seeing all the
contributions by other people and if you
think about it the photo mode is also a
really great marketing tool for the game
because it's going to encourage more
people to share their photos online
using hashtags tagging other people on
social media and I mean if you're the
developer of the game wouldn't you want
it to be shown in its absolute best I
mean looking as good as it possibly can
and photo mode is really a nice way that
you can do that because then you don't
have to worry about all of those HUD
elements and other things showing up now
currently the best way to capture
screenshots in Hogwarts Legacy is if you
have the PC version with Nvidia however
if you're on Console there are a couple
of steps you can take right now to do
just that first of all you can go into
your options disable all of the HUD
items then the other thing you'll want
to do is you'll want to turn on the
Fidelity mode you want the best possible
Graphics frame rate is not a concern
when you're taking screenshots you could
also experiment with the Fidelity Ray
tracing mode if you have a spot where
you feel like the reflections just look
particularly strong now speaking of all
the HUD options that's going to lead us
into our fifth idea and I would love to
see a dynamic HUD option I have to give
the devs a lot of credit here first of
all because they pretty much have all of
the HUD elements where you can turn them
off and while the game looks incredible
this way it's very immersive it can be
very hard to play without seeing the
spell diamonds I can actually get by
most of the time without the mini map
but the spell diamonds they're just too
important when you're in combat when
you're exploring though they're really
not that big of a deal so there are
quite a few examples of games having a
dynamic Hood option and the idea here is
that certain elements would only be
visible when you need them so for my
spell diamond example the Spells but
always show and display when you were in
active combat or anytime you hold the
right trigger to activate a spell
they're going to appear so you can see
them but when you're simply exploring
the world or roaming the halls of
Hogwarts the Spells would automatically
just fade away now our next idea is
involving the game's day night cycles
which believe it or not there actually
is an in-game clock even though you
cannot see this anywhere unless you
actually go to certain places in the
castle and I tested this out this
actually is a real working clock within
the world of course it's not real time
and you can test this by skipping ahead
in time it looks like the game's morning
starts at 6 00 a.m and the evenings
start at 10 pm and if you didn't know
how to do this you can pull up your menu
go to the map choose the weight option
but surprisingly it's not always clear
whether the game is actually reading as
night or day and you'll know this
because there are certain Quest
objectives in Hogwarts Legacy that are
only available at night including both
the demigay statues and the astronomy
tables this is not too much of an issue
with the astronomy tables because
they're going to show up on your map
either way if you go up to one even if
it looks like Knight to you but the
table isn't accessible then you know
okay the game's not reading his Knight
all I need to do is Advance time and
then you'll be able to use it however
where this can be a pain is when you're
searching for demigay statues and you
don't know if it's night or day the
problem here is that the game will
sometimes read as day even though to my
eye at least it appears to be night I
mean I've had times where I'm looking up
at the stars I see the darkness in the
sky I see stars and for whatever reason
the game is still not detecting as night
and now that I know about the clock what
could be happening here is that it could
be in the evening but just before 10 pm
and by looking at that in-game clock
again it seems that 10 pm is the time
that the game officially says okay
here's what we're going to read as night
and the reason this is such a big deal
for the demigay statues is because they
are pretty difficult to find and you'll
need to cast a lot of revelio to find
these and the problem here is that even
when you're casting revelio if it's in
the day you're not going to be able to
see the demigay statues and this one
should not be too difficult to implement
I mean they already have the day night
cycles in the game they already have the
times clearly set up it's just a matter
of us being able to visually tell
whether the game is reading as night or
day when it comes to these missions and
so I think it could be as simple as
putting a little icon on the minimap
that says it's day or even just going
ahead and putting the actual time that
the game is reading I think would be
fine as well but man with those Demi guy
statues trust me I think I would prefer
an option to where I can just instantly
see where the game is reading his night
or day so a little icon on the map I
think would go a long way toward doing
that and for number seven we have bug
fixes unfortunately there are still some
in Hogwarts Legacy now I have to say I
played the vast majority of the game
without experiencing any major issues
some graphical things here and there
unfortunately at the very end once I
finally had my 100 completion I now have
one of the trophy bugs I cannot get the
collector's trophy to pop despite having
all the collections complete Everything
100 across the board you can see it here
that trophy will not pop and I know a
lot of others are in the same boat as
well there's also still an issue with
the biscuit Quest that I know a lot of
people are having trouble with now I can
definitely say that people at Avalanche
are listening they do have a bug fix
site I'll link that down in the
description below I'll also link
directly to the specific problem that
I'm having so if you are also one who's
waiting on that collector's Trophy and
can't seem to get it to work make sure
you go to this page and upvote this
because the things that are uploaded
higher those are what's going to get
prioritized so overall I think it's
clear Hogwarts Legacy did release in a
very solid state when it comes to bugs
however there are still some nagging
things out there that they just need to
iron out and that is something that is
definitely going to benefit both current
players and future players on other
systems now doing this video I know I
teased my ranking of all the Spells so
if you haven't checked that one out yet
that's definitely a good one to go to
next I'll link it here on the right side
of your screen now as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon